I can't really hide from my negative
emotions they they don't so much creep
up on me in the middle of the night as
they burst the door open and smash me in
the face with a hammer spending time
doing self-improvement immediately
posits an ideal as soon as you posit an
ideal you then begin to compare yourself
to that ideal and the Gap is pretty
painful you notice oh my God look at all
of the things that I could should would
be doing but look at how far you've come
you've nailed it you're like a million
miles further ahead than where you were
and almost everybody else as well living
in the Gap is not helping you
Hello friends welcome back to the show
it is a 700 000 subscriber q a episode
so as is tradition I asked for questions
on Twitter and Instagram and locals and
YouTube community and there was lots and
lots uh goes without saying thank you
very much for the support uh growth has
been just insane over the last couple of
months and it's a line continue to go up
uh which is very good so yes let's get
into it first one okay oh yeah also I'm
gonna butcher everybody's usernames
because you don't have easy to renounce
usernames mostly so sorry in advance
ogi Hollywood What stopped you from
caring what others thought when getting
started this is quite an easy one
because when you're getting started no
one is watching the stuff that you're
doing it's one of the advantages of
things in the beginning that if you do
make mistakes no one is there to see
them me and Darren my business partner
when we used to run a bad club night
um we would always it would be a
double-edged sword right because a bad
club night that maybe didn't have many
people attend only a few hundred people
went to it would make us feel bad
because only a few hundred people saw
that there weren't many other people
there but there was only a few hundred
people to see how few people there were
there so it was actually not that bad so
you don't need to worry if you started
worried about starting something no
one's watching you in any case uh up
until the point at which enough people
watch you for you to bother caring
you don't need to care and when you get
to that stage you'll have accumulated
enough experience to not suck at the
thing you're doing
uh coach Owen Miller
do you get nervous before podcasts the
ones with the likes of Goggins Jocko
huberman
Etc uh that's got better over the last
year specifically over the last year
it's got better
um the first and second Peterson ones I
was a little bit antsy I've started to
build up a little pre-routine that I do
during the day of um a type of diet that
I eat
um an amount of exercise that I do a
little pre-game ritual of breath work
and meditation and reading and prep and
then good music and um it's starting to
come down but yeah I I still do get it's
excitement now more than nerves
especially before Goggins I was just
excited and I think this comes as a
byproduct of putting a lot of reps in
the same with anything man like if you
have an undeniable stack of proof that
you can do the thing that you're
supposedly trying to do you should
turn that nervous energy into a good
amount of excitement or at least that's
the way it feels at the moment
Todd Kennedy are you concerned about
burnout you're absolutely killing it
Chris but as my friend wheat waffles
says your type of lifestyle and work
style and a lot of other content
creators are sprinting on a treadmill so
wheat waffles is a black pill YouTuber
from the dating space
um am I concerned about burnout I don't
know man one month's Sprint is another
man's stroll
and my ability to deal with discomfort
in terms of workload is pretty high I
spent all of my 20s working really
really late nights I remember this one
day where me and Darren business partner
drove down to launch our events Company
in Manchester for the first time and I
think we set off at four in the
afternoon we'd worked the whole day
prepping for the event in Newcastle
rented a van from Enterprise Rent-A-Car
set off at four in the afternoon hit
rush hour traffic leaving Newcastle
going across this bridge where everybody
goes over to get out
had to pick up I think three or four
different things like CO2 canisters and
lights and maybe another member of Staff
um on route to Manchester went arrived
at nine o'clock set the club up ran the
event cashed up and then at 2 30 in the
morning or three in the morning when the
event finished we got back in the van
and drove back and dropped everything
off on route back or it might have even
been later it might have been four in
the morning that we left
and then we hit rush hour traffic
getting back into Newcastle across the
same bridge at seven in the morning at 7
30 a.m as the sun was coming up I
remember thinking this is an absolutely
ridiculous routine my point being that
I've uh created a routine of dealing
with discomfort through
um just habit in my 20s it's one of the
things that Peterson said during your
20s work as hard as you can and see what
your tolerance for discomfort is see how
hard you can work and see how hard you
can rest turns out for me that I deal
with rest a lot more poorly than I deal
with work maybe in five years time I'm
going to look back and go oh yeah I was
I was pushing too hard there and I could
have extended my longevity but I've been
doing this at this pace for
three years at three episodes a week and
four years at two episodes a week and
five years one episode a week
and I'm still going at the moment so
fingers crossed
James
Holmgren reading your top 100 books list
love it how did you find the books in
the first place do you have a special
reading technique will there be more
books added in future so if you haven't
got a copy of my reading list it's 100
of the most interesting and impactful
books the most life-changing ones that
I've ever read you can get it at
chriswillx.com books or there will be a
button up here on YouTube and it's free
and it's got links to go and buy them in
description about why I like them and
stuff um how did I find the books in the
first place they were just accumulated
throughout my uh how would you say like
Apprentice ascendancy from total idiot
to slightly less idiot throughout the
back end of my 20s and then the start of
the show uh some of them are from guests
that have been on the show uh do I have
a special reading technique there was a
lot of questions to do with this um
memorization if I have some structure
where how am I able to recall some of
the things that I do dude I I'm not this
isn't me trying to do a humble brag I
was so embarrassed about my recall for
forever ask any of my friends toward the
back end of my 20s I was super
embarrassed because I was listening to
people like Jordan Peterson or Ben
Shapiro or Sam Harris and they just had
this
it felt like an encyclopedia like a
photographic memory which apparently
Shapiro actually has
but it just felt like they could recall
anything that they needed and I was
trying to read this stuff and then would
try and tell my friends about it or
remind myself of it and I couldn't and I
would get so frustrated because I'd
think oh my God like you know these guys
can do it and why can't I do it and it
makes me feel like
and it's just crushing crushing volumes
of time and attention with content I
cared about and then the most important
thing is having an outlet through which
I I had a reason to learn it right I
have a reason to learn this stuff and to
recall it because I have to talk about
it on the show or write about it in the
newsletter the Feynman technique really
really does work uh will there be more
books added in future uh maybe
um I'm trying to grow the mailing list
really really hard so if you haven't got
a copy of that thing go chrislex.com
um I'll do a second volume once I reach
another 100 that I think are
life-changing and I'm probably up to
about 50 now I think since the last one
which was maybe three years ago so uh
yeah at some point
why the ads on the Goggins episode
very glad that you asked this because
had a number of one star and three star
reviews on Apple podcasts because of ads
mid-roll ads on the Goggins episode
which is one episode out of 600 episodes
that I've done
you are free to never listen to the show
again if you have a problem with me
doing two mid-roll ads that last exactly
60 seconds out of a two hour podcast
that cost tens of thousands of dollars
and took six months to plan
feel free to go somewhere else like that
really did get to me the fact that
for the first time ever
I started to do mid-roll ads simply
because it is very very expensive to fly
an entire team a production team out to
Andrew Schultz's studio in New York and
then set everything up and have
everybody on site or with Goggins to
build a custom set inside of a sound
stage in Vegas it was so expensive
um and I like I need to be able to pay
for the people that come out which means
that I need to sell ads on the YouTube
which means that I need to put them into
the episode so yeah I said all along I'm
not a massive fan of mid-roll ads and
I'm not I'm still not I would rather be
able to make the money in a different
way and if I start releasing a product
and make it a bunch of money that can
support the show that way then you can
have the episodes for free but I like I
can't go and just dip it into tens and
tens of thousands of dollars to fund
these shoots and I think if the price
that you have to pay to watch a
cinematic 4K two-hour conversation with
one of the hardest men on the planet is
120 seconds of me talking about two
products that I actually care about
um then that is a fair price I feel like
that's a fair price
um but look
I understand why people don't like them
I'm sorry that they do interject into
the podcast it's easy to skip past but I
also try and make them interesting so I
hope that they are a fair enough balance
fight
Glenn Thompson 93 when is the modern
wisdom merch coming congratulations on
your success so far thank you
uh I'm having conversations at the
moment about merch to be honest I've
realized I'm really bad at monetizing
and turning anything into a business so
it is going slowly but it will be
happening at some point I literally
can't even give you a timeline because
it's all on me if
I really need a business manager like a
brand manager of some kind because the
only way that anything happens is if I
do it and that means I'm always the
bottleneck I'm the bottleneck if we want
to change uh podcast hosting platform
I'm the bottleneck if we want to update
the The Branding and the artwork logo
you remember the logo thing that
happened on
um audio platforms that took
I think five months to do because it's
all on it's a combination of all on me
and all on Dean so
it'll happen at some point and the
designs that we've got are ridiculously
cool they're so good
but I can't give you a date yet sorry uh
Mark kushen thoughts on Alex O'Connor's
recent decision to go back to eating
meat after championing veganism for so
long Alex Alex Alex so
those of you who don't know Cosmic
skeptic Alex O'Connor is a very good
friend of mine
and
he was for a long time an atheist
YouTuber then pivoted into veganism and
then
uh put a community post out saying that
he has begun eating meat not just
exclusively Seafood but also other types
of meats me and Alex have had a couple
of conversations about this I know that
he's going to do a longer term video so
I want a prematurely ejaculate all over
what he's going to talk about but the
bottom line is like
he's still fundamentally believes in the
ethics and the philosophy around
veganism
I think he found the personal toll on
him in terms of his health uh too great
and he wanted to see what would happen
if he switched back to eating meat
the problem is Alex is so ethical like
he's so ridiculously ethical that he
felt like he should tell his entire
audience as soon as he made that
decision as opposed to waiting my advice
for him which I'm happy to tell you
about when he rang me and said should I
do this community post was dude just do
the video like why'd you need to do the
post and he's like oh well it feels a
little bit unethical for me to not tell
people immediately and I was like dude
like that's so a fair play but it's so
unbelievably transparent like and you're
going to take [__] in the interim
between the post and after before the
video so I was like look you need to uh
a fair play like the guy I very much
respect him for the people that don't
know him or are concerned about whether
he's a virtuous human he's like
a fantastic fantastic human I wouldn't
hang around with him if he wasn't so
he's made a personal health decision
like who is anybody to say oh what I
want you to do is sacrifice your health
in service of a a greater cause maybe
you should do but I mean he's done a lot
more for veganism than almost every
vegan on the planet so I don't think
that he's done too badly
Chris
do you have any plans for the 1 million
subscriber episode uh no I really don't
uh perhaps not something that I
considered I would need to think about
given that we only hit
um 100k
two years ago uh I less than two years
ago
um I didn't think that this would be a
thing so any suggestions please let me
know uh
comment I I really don't know what to do
doing another q a like would be cool or
a live stream or maybe a q a from a
special location but
I don't know
scented popsicle personally I think
you're doing great and the production is
great but what are some things you're
trying to improve with future guests or
future episodes so I have a list of big
names that I'm trying to get on this
year
um if I can even get through a quarter
of them I'll be very very impressed and
I think that you guys will be pretty
happy
um
with regards to the production
I do want to do some
uh different locations I don't want to
give away too much just because I don't
want anyone else to do it just yet but
we want to try and do some like really
really insane location shoots which
would be really exciting I've got a
couple of locations in mind uh and then
we're going to try some with different
technology different shooting Styles and
things like that too uh but it's just
rinse and repeat find people that I find
interesting talk to them it's the same
[__] that I did
five years ago when I started the show
like find someone interesting sit down
talk to them the only difference is that
more people watch and listen now that's
it
Apu the contrarian great name any chance
you'll get Naval or Curtis yarvin on the
podcast so Naval is probably as probably
pretty close to number one problem is
that he's taking this massive sabbatical
from podcasts apart from me released
from with David Deutsch the other day
but
um I will he would be like the final
boss in Final Fantasy 9 for me to get on
I would just adore having that
conversation with him and I would do
something so special for the production
as well Curtis yarvin I've met a couple
of times in Austin seems like a nice guy
not super familiar with
that what's it meldibus mold bug thing
that his moniker that he uses online I'm
not really familiar with his work I
don't really understand what I talked to
him about so I'd have to do a lot of
research whereas Nevada like I'm ready
to go Naval if you're listening come on
uh but yeah uh I hope so and Yavin I'll
think about it Owen
Joe Navarro praised you as being one of
the best interviewers stating that he
loved your questioning you truly deserve
all the praise for this thank you I
didn't no I don't know where he said
that uh your genuine curiosity matched
with your ability to ask phenomenal
questions inspires me how did you learn
to ask such good questions so it was a
lot of questions similar to that one
around
um podcasting conversations stuff like
that honestly
it's just time and attention the same as
the learning thing you know I've done
this 600 times and
inevitably you end up accumulating some
good skills some more practical tips
that you could take Beyond like do it
600 times
um think carefully about what you're
going to say what you're trying to say
learn to be as precise as possible with
your speech which means use the right
words assess your language don't berate
yourself if you say the wrong thing or
if you slightly mess up a word or if you
misspeak you don't need to [__] get
the cat of nine tails out and start
whipping yourself
but assessing and listening back to your
performance and saying okay like what
was good what was bad I really love the
way that I used that I really don't like
the way that I did that and then
reviewing game tape of yourself Rogan
and all of the big comedians will review
their comedy sets and say I don't like
that pause I do like this thing
why not do that for conversations or for
podcasting if you genuinely care about
becoming as good as possible at it then
that's something that you should do and
that was something that I did for a good
chunk of the start of the show I would
listen back to episodes and I would
observe my own performance and I would
uh
try not to lambast myself too much but
would critique myself when I got things
wrong
um and then in terms of the actual
questions themselves
just follow your curiosity like you know
what you want to know you know someone's
talking to you and something arises
inside of you that's like it's like
being prodded in the back and you go oh
that I want to know about that what's
that thing and don't be scared of
interrupting you can't go too hard but
if someone if someone hasn't there was a
clip that went a little bit viral online
of me asking Goggins what do you mean
while he was talking because he'd left a
a statement
unqualified or whatever and the only
reason I asked it is because it came up
inside of me it just said I don't know
what he means what do you mean and it
just came out so maybe trying to get out
of your own way a little bit so you need
the skill to be able to do the
communicating bit and then you need to
allow the Curiosity and just turn that
into a monster allow your curiosity to
go on a big hypertrophy program
John Hawk are you anti-woke if so why
what's wrong with being conscious of
racial discrimination in society and
other forms of Oppression and Injustice
I think that being conscious of racial
discrimination thing must be an online
definition of being woke I wouldn't
class myself as anti-woke depending on
like oh using that definition I do think
that some of the like Progressive
overreach and ridiculous
intersectionality gender Dynamics
everything is homophobia transphobia
patriarchal superstructure stuff
not a massive fan of that
but I'm not against people
being for racial like Consciousness and
and understanding oppression and
Injustice and trying to raise up people
from you know uh disempowered groups
like I was that's me I came from
super working-class town you know not a
it's
hardly palatial right like people are
born Live and Die in this place it's not
this is the sort of thing that I would
be for it's incredibly blue in the UK
where I'm from as well not at least it
used to be um they've ruined that a bit
recently but
I wouldn't say that I'm anti-woke
um
I would say that I am concerned about
some of the progressive overreach but
I'm concerned about some of the like
boring
permanently reactionary defensive stuff
that comes from the right as well and
that's getting super boomery recently
too
um from certain areas which is like
something to keep your eye on uh
Constantine kissing had an interesting
tweet where he said the future is not
woke or anti-woke the future is
post-woke
I think that's pretty good
jfx opinions on tap water especially in
the UK good question so I'm really
getting into the quality of water at the
moment at dinner last night this guy is
doing research into aluminum buildup in
people's bodies obviously fluoride in
water has been a big deal for a long
time
in the UK I don't know as much I
certainly know that I don't like the
taste of the water from the TAPS in
America anywhere near as much as I did
in the UK is that just acclimatizing to
The Taste no idea
I have literally just today an hour and
a half ago got off a call with a company
called aqua true and they make a reverse
osmosis uh filtration uh system tabletop
and they can fit it to your house so
I've got a bunch of different things
from them being sent out and I will try
them and I will tell you and if they are
[__] I will tell you as well if I don't
like them I will tell you I promise but
I think that quality of water is going
to be a big consideration and if you're
not thinking about it at the very least
just get a Brita filter it's not doing
that much but it's doing more than
taking it straight out of the tap
um yeah I mean there's even stuff to do
when you're talking about the quality of
water
drinking chilled water is also not
fantastic for you according to some
views of physiology so I I'm like way
too deep down certain rabbit holes
within Austin's Health and Wellness
Community but the problem is I'm not
sufficiently deep I actually know what
I'm talking about so uh yeah I'll report
back but yeah be careful with tap or to
drink as much bottled water as possible
aim for bottled water in glass water if
you can spring water or rainwater is
great
why did you quit modeling
uh out of the country man I think the
last job that I did was just after
covid I was modeling a lot up until
covert happened and then covert happened
and then I got a buzz cut because I
couldn't get my hair cut and I wasn't
going to grow it back out and then all
of my portfolio didn't look like me
because I didn't have the hair of my
portfolio and then uh ruptured my
achilles and lost like a stone in weight
and muscle uh and still would have been
able to go back to it but to be honest I
just I don't want to do anything other
than do the podcast like and have a life
but in terms of work if I was to get I'd
have flown back to the UK to do an ad
for Tesco or something they wouldn't be
able to pay me enough to counteract what
I would lose from not doing the podcast
and also I'd just be thinking about the
podcast like while I'm on a photo shoot
I'd just be wanting to talk to someone
so that's it hello fun enjoyable
industry do it if you've got the
opportunity
Subs P how did you get started with
meditation are there any tools you use
guided meditation apps videos Etc any
books or methods you recommend yes so I
started probably when I was
28 and
the first thing that I used was
headspace I think a lot of people do
Andy body come from headspace
very good uh great starting starting
point
um so I did about 500 sessions guided
through headspace and
um Corey Allen I think it's called
release into now and that is a
meditation that's probably the deepest
guided meditation I've ever done which
has got binaural beats behind it you can
get that if you search Corey without the
e uh Allen
um just search him in meditation and
it'll come up that's great that's really
good buy and now I use a combination of
insight timer for unguided and Sam
Harris is waking up for daily
um just start doing it 10 minutes in the
morning every morning don't miss two
days in a row
and don't overthink it don't berate
yourself if you get distracted just keep
on learning the process and after you
know like 500 sessions you'll become
moderately not incompetent
Richard moly what's your view on
decoding the guru's podcast okay so uh I
was on decoding the gurus coming up on a
year and a half ago now to do a Rite of
reply after they criticized an episode
that I'd done uh and they have got
themselves into hot water recently um
Chris Kavanaugh one of the hosts was
called out by Scott Alexander twice on
two different newsletters uh Constantine
kissing from trigonometry had a problem
with them
they are able to poke people in a very
tender spots and they were able to rile
them up
um I think one of the reasons that they
cause uh a little bit of I mean Sam
Harris went back on so did I uh Robert
Wright went back on
uh Constantine kissing went back on
Jamie wheel went back on I think one of
the reasons is that the their ability to
have fun whilst doing this is quite
admirable like it it is
they're evidently enjoying themselves
which means that you think oh well [__]
maybe there's some truth in this because
it's not just it doesn't feel like it's
just out to be snide but there is some
sometimes like
um
vicious topspin applied to the things
that they say so I can understand why it
it causes people
um like discontent for me personally it
was a very important corrective measure
I have a lot to thank Chris and Matt
about
um even though it's got not necessarily
that this was the reason they were doing
it or perhaps even anything that they
intended to do but one of the byproducts
of turning some lead into gold with this
I alchemized my experience on decoding
the gurus um because I was certainly not
thinking enough about balance on the
show
um and this was just before Rogan was
about to do his uh double whammy of
first the Robert Malone thing and then
the n-word video and it just all came
together and I speak to Chris like
moderately regularly like I'd I'd say
that we're mates and we talk about
all sorts of stuff that's going on in
the world and you know even though
that's not the sort of show that I do I
uh they enjoy it man and like
I don't know it's it was useful for me
as a Creator it was a useful corrective
measure and I appreciate the fact that
uh they stepped in and told me where I
was going wrong
Jewels drums how do you stay impartial
or at least compartmentalize your
partiality during interviews this is
super easy I I if I think I know what
you're getting at which is I just want
to find out what the person's saying I
just want to ask questions and if you
ask questions
you will
inevitably end up
kind of slicing through any of the
biases or concerns or
um existing stances that you have for
instance the David lay episode the uh
one of the world's leading cook
researchers if you missed this one go
back and check that out
um he you know I I I make no bones about
it I don't think that cooking makes any
sense
evolutionarily psychologically socially
it just it blows my mind that people can
do this to watch porn about it let alone
allow it to happen in their lives
and but I was interested I'm like look I
want to find out and I think
if you go into a conversation believing
that the other person genuinely has
something interesting to say to you
or to add to your conversation
that
you can't really go wrong like you're
just going to continue to find out more
and even if you disagree with what it is
that they're saying if your pursuit of
knowledge takes precedence over
everything else then
uh it seems to work for me and I yeah it
comes across as impartiality I suppose
uh even if I'm not all the time and you
know there will come a time when
something crosses the line I said it
with David I was like look I don't think
it doesn't matter what you say I don't
think that using porn to educate
um like underage
kids even if they are teenagers that are
maybe sexually active I don't I struggle
to find a place to stand firmly on that
ethically
um there are points and walls at which
I'll do that but I'll ask more questions
and that seems to like diffuse tensions
quite nicely
cryptic 15. I totally get the idea
behind the phrase do not Outsource your
self-worth to the world yet at the same
time the combined wisdom and foresight
of the world is much larger than our own
as Jordan Peterson says we Outsource our
sanity to the world how do we strike a
balance between avoiding being a
grandiose narcissistic person and
avoiding being a people pleaser with no
genuine sense of their own self-value
very good question dude you all of the
questions are
awesome
this audience is so insightful I really
really appreciate all of the questions
that you guys ask so just interjection
thank you
um
do not Outsource your sense of
self-worth to the world and yet the
world has more insight and foresight
around us than everyone else yeah it's
it's difficult I would say that
um this is one of those times where
the at different stages of your
development this will be more and less
appropriate so don't Outsource your
sense of self-worth to the world may be
more useful as you become a little bit
more mature and a more well settled and
understand your own capacities and can
have faith in your own abilities but at
the beginning of any Endeavor using a
little bit of feedback from the people
around you is a good idea right like you
don't want to just be a single-minded I
know what I'm doing person if you've
never done this thing before you need to
get some feedback if you walked onto a
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu mat and said I know
what I'm doing with BJJ didn't listen to
the coach at all and just kept on
getting tied up but didn't listen to the
feedback then you're you're evidently
dispelling obvious wisdom that could
help you in what it is that you're doing
so perhaps one of the balances to look
at here is how much Insight do I have
and how much experience do I have and
how much should I take from this person
does this person have my best interests
at heart do they actually have
experience and expertise and what
they're talking about do I have any
countervailing evidence that suggests
that I don't need to listen to them I
think that would be a balance
a healthy dose of self-belief in things
that you have earned it in a healthy
dose of feedback in situations where you
feel like you need it and then play with
those two scales appropriately Mrs
Anthony Bridgeton when will you start to
tour like Jordan Peterson
okay so
um there has been a lot of conversations
about this uh like more I think this is
probably the first time I mentioned it
on the show a lot of conversations about
doing a live show
uh
I'm still not even of the like I still
can't believe the size of the show so my
sense of identity is playing catch-up uh
with where the show is at now uh but it
would be really cool to do and I'm quite
excited about the prospect of kind of
like the lessons the 14 lessons from
2022 or the five year anniversary or the
like the big episodes the 100th episode
things that I do I would love to do an
extended version of that perhaps with a
little bit of production live that would
be awesome and I mean to tour doing this
would be exciting
um so I think
at some point this year there will be
maybe one or two UK dates and one or two
US states where I can test this show
live and start to play around with the
ideas I am going to do a few spots one
in Miami at the start of March
wanted the International Fitness Summit
in Brighton
in August or September and one in Dubai
I think in October I'm going to do one
at each of those where I'm going to test
the show as well
um and then yeah maybe next year there
will be a a bigger more well put
together show or tour which sounds
insane to say and I would absolutely
love to see every single one of you
there bill will you play cricket again
no it snapped my achilles the last time
that I'm playing uh I would need an
awful lot more reassurance before I can
do that went back to playing it after 10
years off ruptured my achilles not too
quickly
Jay Liu what's the song at the beginning
of every podcast I literally make sure
to listen to it every time [__] what's
it called uh
fly
away uh
uh you're gonna have to ask it again on
the 800th episode sorry
um it's something it's a dubstep remix
that I found on Creative Commons license
six years ago and it was a remix of a
dubstep song I really wanted something
that was high energy but had the melody
in and
um yeah for the people that only ever
watch on YouTube there is an entire
segment of the podcast that you don't
listen to because I will do an intro
spoken intro to the guest which lasts
about a minute then maybe some comments
about the episode and then I'll do some
ad reads and then maybe some more
comments and then the episode will begin
after a particular piece of music so uh
yeah you're missing out if you don't
subscribe on Spotify but I you'll have
to ask again because I I'll get it ready
for the next one I promise uh Christian
von
uffle what is an important change you
think is happening right now that people
don't talk enough about declining birth
rates and the impact of hormonal birth
control on women's psychology I think
both of those are huge I think that in
future historians are going to look back
and think
what the [__] are we doing how did we
let this happen how did nobody foresee
this
um it wouldn't surprise me if declining
birth rates are the number one
existential risk no it wouldn't be a
true existential risk because it's not
going to take us beyond the brink of
unrecoverable collapse
like a a an existential catastrophe
let's say um birthrights 100 uh
here we go
wacky
Pataki Waki Pataki
uh will he be on the JRE podcast anytime
soon
um
maybe I haven't spoken to Joe in a
little while uh I need to send him a
documentary that I saw that I thought
was cool he'll reach out he just he's
got his own schedule the same as me and
I'm looking forward to the next time
that I get to speak to him uh when
ever that happens uh but it was so much
fun the first time was just bags and
bags of fun so yeah when we go round two
I'm very much looking forward to he said
some very nice things after the last one
so yeah um
hopeful
Eric is dating a bad idea for young men
right now is focusing on growth and
success of the self of us focusing on
growth and success over sex and romance
a wise move for an ambitious person I
don't believe the trouble of mundating
is worth sacrificing the time and effort
I can put into myself or my career but I
still feel intense fomo maybe there is a
balance love the podcast you keep me
going through my monotonous 10 hour
shifts keep it up man well fair play
grinding away a 10 hour shifts Eric
that's pretty impressive
personally for me like going through
periodized monk modes is a great idea
but committing to it for the rest of
time doesn't seem smart I don't think
that saying dating is a bad idea for
young men right now makes a whole lot of
sense it no absolutely not like
sex is on the bottom of Mazda's
hierarchy of needs I fundamentally
disagree with the view that humans on
average or even like
Beyond a very small cohort of people can
exist without having a life partner I
just don't think that it's the way that
we're designed I mean you can but you're
going to be it's going to be a
sub-optimal life
I would say the same as my suggestion
about sobriety right periodize it I'm
gonna go
single and monk mode for a bit and I'm
gonna date for a bit and see how that
goes and then maybe I'll go back to monk
mode and then I'll go back to dating you
don't need to commit for the rest of
time
um I think that working on yourself
before you bring somebody else in
especially if you've got baggage and
stuff that you need to deal with and
development and goals that you want to
achieve is great but I think completely
closing off the potential for romantic
uh connection is just not a smart idea
like the person that could be perfect
for you to spend the rest of your life
with could go past you and if you're
just if you've decided in advance to
make a completely arbitrary decision
that I am not in the place to find a
partner right now even if you could be
I think that you are capping your
success and I don't think that
exclusively looking at growth and
personal development is all that there
is in life I think that there is more
Rebecca Tom milty you mentioned in a
recent podcast that increasing your
vocabulary really helps you to
articulate your thoughts and improve
your communication do you have any hints
tips methods for how to improve your
vocabulary thanks so much for a great
podcast and show thank you Rebecca
um for me reading different books and
then seeing words that I don't know and
getting really excited about seeing the
words and then trying to use them or
trying to teach them to somebody so I'll
go to the gym with Zach on the morning
and I'll be telling him about something
that I learned when I read so I read for
about 15 minutes on the morning which is
much but during it I'll really think
okay what the [__] did I learn this
morning I learned about
um like a usefully irrational beliefs or
what's it called we can tell how well
I've remembered it
fictionally rationable beliefs or
something anyway that was that was this
morning from gwynda and I'll try and
teach it to him or a new word or
something like that and I'll try and
like chip away for a good while reading
different sorts of books reading books
from outside of this time and listening
to people that use broad vocabulary you
know if you hear one of the guests on
the show say something cool I learned
the word conniptions the other day which
is kind of like a fit of rage
um
I was like immediately ask the person
what does that mean they told me and
then I like conniptions pretty cool like
it's it's cooler than saying a fit of
rage so I'm going to start using it but
you do need to make sure that you're
using in the right context minutia Chris
needs millions of subscribers one of
five top channels on the internet I
couldn't agree more thank you yes
uh Jake Parker what are your thoughts on
writing a book during a time in which AI
May soon be able to write it better and
faster uh yeah I mean I [__] man like I
should just keep drinking deceiver and
chill out but
one of the things that you need to
remember about the way that chat GPT
works is it's a prediction engine right
it's basically predictive text but just
strung out across sentences paragraphs
and then pages
so although it may be
uh able to convey quite simple
information effectively it's never going
to be original like by definition it's
not going to be original because all
it's done is it's a language learning
model that has taken existing work and
then this is how they're able to work
out plagiarism in schools you can run
text that has been generated by chat GPT
through a filter and it is able to work
out how predictable the sequence of
words were and if it hits a particular
threshold it's obvious that it's been
written by that because we don't write
all humans don't write with this uh
preconceived parameters of
predictability so I'm not convinced it
would be able to make it faster and
better it'd definitely be able to make
it faster than I can I don't write that
quickly
um but I don't know like it's not just
the project of me writing something
isn't just for me to
it's a learning project for me as well
like and I'm not going to learn by
watching chat gbt write my book for me
uh and if Bing takes over then it's
going to be a battle between chat GP
team being in any case and we'll just
observe the Terminator War of the
world's thing going on
cold pepper keep going bro your genuine
honest approach is much appreciated
an environment filled with lies and half
truths
thanks man I appreciate that I really do
Jordan Spencer not a question but your
podcasts have changed my outlook on life
oh thank you that's about as good of a
testimonial as I could ask for
the username Beck how do your parents
feel about your success
uh good uh mum listens to most of the
episodes dad uh drops in every so often
I think he got half of the goggles
episode
um they're just happy that I'm happy I
go genuinely I'm happy and I love doing
what I'm doing and I think that that's
all that they ever wanted for me and
they got out of my way very quickly they
gave me sufficient latitude to do which
is the opposite that you hear of only
child parents right the helicopter thing
um they just moved out of my way as soon
as I went to UNI and just seemed to have
a lot of faith in me being able to do my
stuff which I'm incredibly appreciative
of I've never felt pressure to have to
do anything
um
yeah I think
the happy that I'm happy which is pretty
good
mercs 80s do you miss the UK I do
actually I I have been feeling a little
bit culturally sort of displaced
um every so often in America because I
it sounds stupid but
the things that you hold on to like the
cultural artifacts you know making jokes
about
Greg's or the Tyne Bridge or accents
from where you are they're an important
part of culture they're an important
uh like ingredient of the way that you
came up and to not be able to do that
and to have to it's so much more
effortful for me to try and be
um like funny or or culturally
charismatic or anything over here
because I don't know what I'm talking
about I don't know what Cool Whip is and
I don't know like stories about the
Barry Bonds and stuff I don't I don't
have the same cultural anchoring so I do
miss the UK in that regard
um I miss the amount of Nature and the
type of nature as well that's not to say
that Austin doesn't have some nice
nature it does and I do prefer the
weather here
um but every time that I go home and
especially this winter when I went home
for Christmas it was one of the best
times that I've had and I I'm enjoying
loving the UK again when I get to go
back it doesn't feel as much like a
prison as it does like a holiday uh and
that's pretty cool
Lou Simpson 24 what haircut do you have
had a lot of questions about this over
the last few weeks like what number hair
could I go for and you've chosen a good
day because I literally had this done
today so it is a two and a half on the
top and it is a two on the sides and
it's squared off on the back and I get
it done about every three weeks and that
keeps it pretty much like this
whole Diary of a CEO when
so this is Stephen Bartlett's podcast uh
biggest podcast in the UK I think by
plays on average at the moment across
all categories
um
soon I don't want to say but it you
won't be waiting long I don't think
Paul
hogben 23 do you keep all the books you
read I do yes actually unless I gift
them um but you can see this uh thing
for the people that are just listening
it's the vertical bookcase that has the
blue light behind me in the recording
studio and
um that has been slowly filling up if
you actually go back to the really
really early episodes in this house
you'll see that the books were super low
and over time it's it's filling up like
a loading bar
um I left so I must have left hundreds
of books in the UK which did make me
quite sad uh but I'm accumulating more
so yeah I keep them all
uh Hamza 6969 please call Ray dalio in
your podcast if you haven't Ray dalio is
booked on the podcast he's coming on to
talk about his two most recent books one
of which I think is like a journal uh
which will be pretty exciting to talk
about but yes I finally got through to
him I'd wanted to bring him on for ages
principles is great book
um so yeah Ray dalio have me rigatoni
how do you avoid negative self-talk
causing poor performance causing more
negative self-talk Etc yeah this is
um something that I've
battled with for quite a while I'm
currently
mercifully in a uh however you would say
like a positivity phase
um I wonder whether I'm going to Peak
and then come back down to a more
negative self-talk phase but for a long
time I'm talking like a decade uh
negative self-talk and and a very
unhelpful critical voice in my mind uh
was a Mainstay like it was it was the
primary voice that I hear very scathing
very
um vicious uh very mocking
um patronizing uh passive aggressive
voice that I had uh every time that I
fell short of my
um promises that I made to myself or
goals that I'd set for myself or the
comparison game between me and other
people
um I'm very familiar with that and then
obviously what it does is it gets you
nervous about your ability to do a thing
which means that you do the thing more
poorly which reinforces the fact that
your bad self-talk told you that you
couldn't do the thing
it's not good
um the way that I fixed that was
performance first and this is probably
I'm sure that there is a performance
psychologist out there that's just
sticking his hands in his face but in my
opinion leading with your performance
first just going out there getting on
the stadium floor trying as hard as you
can to do a thing as well as you can
Little Steps making promises to yourself
keeping them over and over again
and then allowing your identity to catch
up with that and eventually you have an
undeniable stack of proof that you are
who you say you are right you've
outworked that self-doubt you've
outworked that negative self-talk
that seemed to work for me
is music
if you were to start modern wisdom all
over again with the same five years of
experience what would you do I'm gonna
guess you mean like what would you do
differently than I did in the first
instance
not much to be honest I was pretty happy
with the way that everything went I
it was slow and brutal for 300 episodes
or three years
um but it was still fun like it was only
brutal in that there was no one
listening to the podcast like relatively
to now
nothing I don't think I'd change
anything genuinely
uh
uh Tim
organ91 hi Chris love the podcast and
your recommendation of baccarat Rouge
540 was a game changer any others so
baccarat Rouge is a fantastic fragrance
for both men and women it's supposed to
be unisex but no idea I don't know how
I'd feel if I um was with a girl who was
wearing it but uh it's it's amazing uh
other ones
um halffetti by pentaligans is
really really nice it's a little bit
more aggressive it's less oily than the
baccarat Rouge but it's very nice
um
not aventus by Creed but there is one I
want to say it's called Everest or
Himalaya or something it's in a silver
bottle and it's Super Fresh that's
absolutely lovely and then uh Cairo I
think it's halfetti Cairo by pentaligans
as well those are some more but if you
haven't tried pental against halfetti
that will blow your face off it's so
good but it's not quite as good as
baccarat Rouge 540
um sorry women I don't know any good
girls fragrances uh Robbo clock what
brand are your t-shirts this was another
hair and t-shirt t-shirts have been
asked about a lot Zara to all of the
guys that have been asking what the
T-shirt was that I wore on Goggins what
the one was that I wore on Tom Bilu what
the one was I wore with Schultz pretty
much every podcast
I think every big podcast that I've done
has been Zara I almost exclusively wear
Zara for smart clothing Zara sponsor me
um
and I wear I'm 5 10 and a half
190 pounds or like 90 kilos and I wear
an XL in their fitted t-shirts and they
are fantastic they're really really good
highly recommend them
Pierre August you mentioned a few times
that you were the most hated guy in
school any reason why I don't think I
said most hated I think I said least
popular uh I may have managed to hold
both titles at the same time uh but I
certainly least popular uh why was I the
least popular guy in school
I just really struggled to connect with
other kids I just didn't know how to
socialize you know I I had had a
like relatively socially isolated
upbringing as being an only child and
having some Tendencies of introversion
uh so it's not like mum and dad stopped
me from doing things you know I went and
played Sports I played football I did
Judo and then I played qriket for a long
time at a very high level a lot
I don't know maybe I was just a bit like
socially autistic I'm not sure I just I
didn't I didn't understand how social
stuff worked and I would obsess over
weird things that people did about the
type of trousers they wore or the way
that They Carried their bag and I'd be
adamant that that was what made them
cool it wasn't it was the fact that they
could communicate normally with other
children and I didn't understand that
that was what was going on uh and it's
like it's been a really really long
effortful uh this is how to be a human
in a group.com instructional video thing
for me to actually get to that stage
however
have got to the stage now
where it comes a lot more second
naturally to me which is lovely
ciao down food
how knackered were you after the podcast
with Cam
um the podcast was fine the issue was
the day before so the lift run shoot
that we've done for the people that
don't know I was on Cameron haynes's
podcast he is this world class bow
hunter incredibly hard man endurance
racing dude it's like a like a white
Goggins that's got a bow in his hand
basically and I went to Oregon with him
and he made me run up a hill a lot and
it was hard uh and then he made me do
100 reps of bench
225 with chains and then we did
we shot some bows and it it was
difficult
um
but it was very fun and I he we have
been texting a lot and he's a great guy
and I very much understand why a lot of
people respect him he's super cool dude
tosty
is the mating crisis as critical as made
out not just patterns being shifted back
by 10 years so I think what you mean by
this is
if uh people choose to get into
relationships later I maybe a decade
later
um why is that a big deal people are
still going to pair off the problem is
that you have this uh immovable window
of female fertility right you have a
fertility window that is a pretty hard
Line in the Sand between the ages of
whatever 38 and 48 varies very broadly
for a lot of women
um
I think that Downstream from The Mating
crisis the main concern that I have
Steven Shaw's concerned about population
collapse which I am as well but first
and foremost I'm concerned about
individual happiness and I just think
that
the longer the people stay single the
evidence suggests the less likely they
are to be able to find a partner that
they're going to be happy with so the
longer that you do this the longer that
you remain out of a relationship the
less and less likely it is that you're
going to get into one that makes you
feel happy and we know that on average
most people
should be in a relationship if they want
to maximize their relation their
happiness in life
not for everybody but it is for almost
everybody right
um I think it's a big deal which is why
I care about it a lot um yep we can push
things back
um but you know four out of five women
who didn't have kids didn't intend to
not have kids
that seems like a big deal to me and
that's almost exclusively because of the
patterns being shifted back by 10 years
if that's what you meant
um that's it that is what we're talking
about right these women that burst
through the fertility window that meant
to have children that didn't realize how
late it was that then try that then
grieve over families that they never had
it's brutal amount I hear about these
stories and it makes me feel so sad
um
and it should make everyone feel sad you
know
Ryan
Segal uh what are your thoughts when you
run into someone in person who's been
impacted by the Pod uh this is a good
question because it's happening a lot
more uh now which is beautiful
um but kind of
odd um I'm not massively used to it
especially because a lot of the podcast
consists of me in a room I'm not doing
live shows yet I'm not going out and and
and Performing anywhere I don't I go out
with my friends and we'll go for dinner
and we'll do stuff and we'll go to the
gym but
for the most part it's just me grinding
away right doing my thing
I was in camuna 13 which is the
X
most hardcore drug lord ridden dangerous
part of Medellin Colombia
few last week
this is a place that's got escalators
outside to go up and down because it's
so hilly it's like
amazing Vibe like fascinating Vibe very
very
um outgoing and loud and vibrant
and I get to the bottom of one of these
escalators on the way back to the truck
to go back to the hotel and this dude
stopped me and said hey Chris uh I just
wanted to let you know that you're the
reason that I left my job and um now I'm
here in Colombia and I'm traveling and I
can't say enough for how the show has
impacted me and blah blah blah and it is
a little bit like I I almost feels like
people are paid actors
um to do that so this is great man it
makes me feel so happy it's like it's
beautiful to to see that something that
I enjoy doing so much impact other
people in a positive way it's great like
it's a Dream It's a dream uh so yeah
cool
uh the batch ear Chi uh get Peter attire
to your podcast huberman put me and him
in a text thread two weeks ago and I'm
speaking to his bookings PR personal
assistant man uh he will be on I will
get Peter out here on the show all
things being well Peter actually will be
on the show this year he's got a new
book out that you should check out it'll
be on Amazon for pre-order uh you should
do that but yeah thank you as well
heberman for linking us up
I've never seen you wearing anything but
Vans why
Goods point I have been in a big Vance
uh like
Flex for a little while
um they're just so I think that Vans
might be the most versatile shoes on the
planet you could run in them you could
lift in them you could do something up
and to formal dress in them and you
could do casual in them that they work
with shorts they work with jeans they're
[__] phenomenal and if you get what's
called The Comfy Kush version which is
maybe 10 pounds or dollars more they put
a special soul in and it's ridiculously
comfortable you could wear them all day
it's absolutely fine
I just I really love them they're just
they're great I find them absolutely
fantastic uh so right now the Wardrobe
of shoes is a combination of Vivo
barefoot
uh Reebok Nanos
uh Nike Pegasus 35s for walking and
running
Crocs and vans that's my that's the
five-car garage of uh of shoes uh
fontivity Colin
Colton uh are you concerned about emfs
from devices like airpods Etc do you use
wide or Wireless so
from what I know the radiation that
comes out of airpods is non-ionizing
I don't know what the [__] that means
but someone smart told me that I don't
need to worry about it so I'm not
bothered about it and airpods don't seem
too I mean the advantage of wearing a
pair of airfod
the advantage of wearing a pair of
airpods outweighs the future brain
cancer that I may end up threatening
myself with because they're just so good
it says everything about how good
airpods are that I'm prepared to throw
brain cancer down on the line that's
that's the price that I'm prepared to
pay if I'm allowed to walk around my
house at a 10 meter radius listening to
whatever it is I need to listen to
uh
huh
Ariana
volander
is bald [__] still a thing do guys care
about women having pubic hair uh look
Ariana
I can't speak for all men
um I know my preference and I I do think
that guys care about women having pubic
hair if I have to fight through a
Thicket to
find what I'm trying to discover
that's not very good is it I mean
the difference in a guy having pubic
hair and a girl having pubic hair is
that
what you're looking for isn't hidden
behind ours unless someone has really
really grown it out this dude's you know
got a full-on afro
I think ball [__] is still a thing I'm
gonna
I know this is a controversial statement
this may be one of the most
controversial things that I've ever said
in my entire life
but I do think that bold [__] is still
a thing
Owen [__] whoa did you just skip
straight past 600k no I did a 600k uh q
a as well which you should go and uh
check out we should go and listen to it
uh Danny colopi what does your usual
chest day at the gym look like good
question okay so I would typically do
um back first my chest day starts with
back that's what that's how mine Begins
the reason for that is that all of my
chest exercises feel better if I have
got myself into sort of this shoulders
back and down position so something like
um four sets of rpe seven uh 10 to 14
rep uh horizontal row of some kind
seated row seal row something like that
and just get those shoulders back and
down then it would be incline bench uh
one to two warm-up sets and then four
working sets with a drop set at the end
that would be with dumbbells
then what would we move on to after that
uh probably
flat bench
uh or weighted dips
then
machine flies
uh machine fly machine and maybe finish
off with weighted push-ups or something
similar all of those are four sets of
eight to Fourteen and the final set is
always a drop or a double drop set
um I'm sure that there's a better way to
periodize this but I'm just I'm still
the same bro that went to Newcastle
Uni's Center for sporting Excellence 15
years ago and we just did drop sets at
the end of everything so I'm just in
that Rhythm uh where we
Sean uh hi Chris I started listening
last year and I'm a huge fan
listen during my workouts and morning
shifts absolutely love your discussions
on behavioral psychology and
self-improvement always brightens my day
and I must give you a most heartfelt
thank you thank you very much very
meaningful
question what advice would you give to
someone who is a jack of all trades but
a master of none no real friend groups
and feels like they have nothing to
offer the world beyond their curiosity
and want to stand out or create content
also return to college at age 26 to
study Health and Human Performance and
Physical Therapy another seven to ten
years what the hell do I do well first
off you have all of the foundational
makings of someone that is going to
succeed at whatever you do because you
are prepared to swallow your own Pride
to go back and do something which is
non-typical at that age like you are
going to be significantly older than
most of the other people at Uni that's
great uh you have a good amount of
self-awareness that you can you know
where some of your weaknesses are it's
evident that you're relatively humble
and have got your feet on the ground
you're going to be absolutely fine
um I would try as best you can
especially given that you're at college
now to just expose yourself to as much
as possible join the Improv School Play
Ultimate Frisbee start doing Tai Chi go
to knitting class like do all of the
things because it sounds like you're
yearning for a passion that will come
and take hold of you
the problem is that you don't have that
passion quite yet if you're a jack of
all trades but the master of none you
only need one or two of those things to
cross over
and you you're going to be unbelievably
good
so expose yourself to lots of things
find something that you become obsessive
about and just let it consume you like
let it
whatever it is that you find that you
really really want to do
spend enough time exploring try
different things discover a thing you
love and then let it infect You Like A
Parasite and stare out of your eyes that
seems to be the way that most people
that I know that do something that they
love and that becomes a part of them
kind of let the world work
Spooner Sean
as growth continues can you see a time
when the podcast alone stops exciting
you where you feel the need to add in
something else to the mix as you tick
off more and more numerical goals and
dream guests can intrinsic motivation
last beyond the point where this stops
feeling like a challenge
Ah that's a good question
it's difficult for me to have theory of
mind about who I'm going to be in future
because
I'm not there yet
it's not stopped exciting me yet is what
I can tell you
and
there is still so much more Headroom
for me to step up into I think
and also
the personal development productivity
background that aren't a massive number
of people I don't think talking about
this kind of personal development with
the human behavior
evolutionary psychology cognitive
science approach that are just saying
look here's a ton of research how does
this make you feel how does this impact
your life
do what you want with this information
maybe I could be more applied maybe I
could say you should this is the
solution from this thing and this is
this and this is that when we do the
life hacks episodes but that's telling
you how to create a great toasted
sandwich or like where to sleep in
Amsterdam airport where there aren't arm
rests in between the seats
I think that there's a lot of impact
still to be had from this
show and from what I like to focus on
and I still have a ton of self-work to
do as well and like research is me
search is I call I learned from William
Costello which is basically people
research the things that they need to
learn about in their own lives and the
show is absolutely that reflection for
me too so for as long as I am an as yet
unactualized human you're coming along
for the ride and hopefully it's useful
uh with that
I could imagine that if you reach the
Zenith of whatever it is maybe it needs
to be something else but you know then
we add in live shows maybe or we add in
a a business or a company that trains
other people I don't know like just does
stuff there's always going to be ways to
tack little things onto the side of
whatever it is that this show is and
this sort of modern wisdom
philosophy has become or that the
approach to life has become uh and I
think it's going to be
a relatively infinite game I hope
Claire McLeod congrats amazing numbers
happy birthday uh
don't think it's my birthday oh it will
have been my birthday by the time that
this was out wish me happy birthday uh
an hour and a bit into a podcast wish me
happy birthday my question is I'd be
interested to hear about who slash what
data convinced you read a stem cell
treatment and what rehab program slash
Aftercare returning to training is thank
you love your show thank you Claire
um
stem cell treatment I went to Columbia I
received about 200 million stem cells
over the space of six days uh into my
shoulders into my knees into my back
into my achilles IV received 100 million
as well
um there seems to be some promising
research when you get them at the
concentrations that they're allowed to
do outside of America the rehab program
will be a lot of time and attention I'm
going to get even smaller which makes me
super sad because I'm not going to be
able to go crazy hard in the gym while I
let the stem cells do their thing but I
am looking forward to the injury injury
recovery and uh like Rehabilitation
revitalization prevention longevity
stuff all kicking in Aftercare is a lot
of walking at the moment for me
um I am spending as much time as I can
just trying to stay active I'm stood up
right now trying to stand up as much as
possible
um
yeah it was a really cool experience
physically pretty uncomfortable
emotionally pretty enjoyable but it's
not for the faint of heart if you've got
a low pain tolerance like it's
you're going to know about it lj22 great
to see the podcast going from strength
to strength congratulations thank you is
the scheduling of upcoming episodes more
of an art or a science do you look at
the numbers to see for Monday Thursday
or Saturday is a prime spot for a big
guest or what days of the week pull in
the greatest amount of views or do you
use your instinct and intuition to
appropriately spread out certain topics
and subjects is there anything that
makes a guest or topic film on
monday-ish or thursday-ish or are these
data driven decisions uh there's a
really good question actually I don't
think I've ever been asked this before
but yeah I do I tend to try and have
stuff on a Monday which will require a
little bit more reflection because
Monday is the only day where there's
three days between that episode going
out and a new one going out it's a
slightly longer episodes sometimes tend
to be on a Monday ones that are um maybe
going to need a little bit more
Reflection from people tend to go out on
a Monday uh Thursday episodes tend to be
something similar
although maybe a tiny little bit of a
step down and then the Saturday episodes
are I sometimes try to make them a
little bit more of an easy listen it's
not massively data driven
um Saturdays do sometimes underperform
compared with the other days of the week
but uh YouTube is the other way around
sometimes Thursdays don't perform too
well uh we probably should be publishing
on a Sunday because Sunday's the most
active day but to be honest I just
I made this decision arbitrarily because
I was like okay Monday will be a good
day to release a podcast uh because
everyone's gonna start the week and
they'll know it's modern wisdom Monday
and then I needed to do two a week so I
said well Thursday that's good that's
another day of the week Friday would be
weird because everyone's waiting for the
week the weekend to come around to
Monday Thursday and then when I needed
to do another one the only day I could
do was Saturday and now I've got lock in
so uh here we are
Henry Webster I'm starting my caffeine
free Journey after drinking a lot of
coffee since at least my early teens 20
years ago I've quickly noticed that Not
only was I using caffeine to give me
energy requiring more and more to just
reach a base level but I had come to use
caffeine to cover up negative emotions
did you have any such personal insights
when you stopped drinking caffeine
thanks Chris been here since under 50K
and Still Loving It Henry Henry irinoji
thank you uh yeah dude I mean people use
caffeine as a
but not only a mood enhancer but a mood
stabilizer I feel bad today okay I'll
pump a bunch of caffeine in and I don't
know I'm sure Cuban will be able to tell
you what's going on but there is some
Cascade of things you know a good a good
strong caffeinated drink with some good
music and it's you're flying it feels
really good uh so yes you will
absolutely use it to cover up negative
emotions uh the lifestyle things I think
I've spoken about Ad nauseam
um covering up your fatigue you're not
looking after your health you're not
looking after your sleep hygiene and
you're using caffeine as a buttress to
keep yourself going everybody knows this
already from hearing me hop on about it
um the emotional thing is super super
interesting and definitely something I
noticed and something that I haven't
spoken about so very much appreciate you
reminding me of it
um
yeah I had to cover up negative emotions
if you're feeling a little bit down and
you crack a big coffee into yourself it
kind of you're so wired and focused and
just on edge that it doesn't really
matter what
is going on uh you you just you're just
gonna blast through it with your
caffeinated snowplow so yes
I did I did notice those things although
um I'd done I was pretty far down the
old like self-work route and I was
facing my negative emotions pretty face
on I can't really hide from my negative
emotions they they don't so much creep
up on me in the middle of the night as
they burst the door open and smashed me
in the face with a hammer so I didn't
really need
to go caffeine free to uh be aware of
them they were they were front and
center
Jared not congrats dude when we're
talking about moving toward projects or
goals what is your advice or how did you
learn to just sit down and do the thing
feels like a muscle that needs to be
built although the barriers often feel
overwhelming keep up the awesome work
thank you uh and yeah the do the thing
or just do the thing is something that
I've been thinking about a lot
um I keep tweeting it once a week
probably on Twitter your weekly reminder
to just do the thing and
Stephen pressfield says this in the war
of art
um real writers know that the difficulty
isn't the writing part the difficulty is
the sitting down to right part and that
is it how many times have you put off
doing a task
or you've procrastinated your way
through a task but you haven't actually
started it's not like you got into the
task and got distracted and stopped it
you didn't begin the task so yes sitting
down and doing the thing is a muscle
that needs to be built
um some of the things that you can do
cold turkey which is a
um app for MacBook maybe available for
Windows as well which can literally
block websites and applications on your
computer and it will stop you from using
things and you can't get around it it
won't let you use this stuff unless you
donate money to charity now to you that
chooses what times it's on what times
it's off if it's on if it's off which
websites which applications
Etc but um that's a good way to start
because it just reminds you like hey
[__] you're supposed to be working
um
in terms of building up the muscle
making it as frictionless as possible to
go from the state of not doing the work
to the state of doing the work in terms
of planning your day allowing yourself
to have long uninterrupted blocks with
which to do it let's say that this is
disgusting but probably true of the most
people that it takes you 30 minutes to
start doing the thing right let's say it
takes you 30 minutes if you have a
meeting in an hour's time you get 30
minutes of work at most whereas if you
have organized your day so think okay I
know that I'm going to have to pay an
entry price to do this thing I'm gonna
have to sit down and make myself feel
like [__] and like listen to the right
music and Fiddle around with my desk and
brush the Dust Away from whatever it is
and get distracted and then eventually
I'll sit down and do the work
and I have this long and uninterrupted
period to do after that in which I can
do more work that's a good way to
structure your day so those would be
some things and then after that if you
do begin to do the work
once you have got through a period of it
just give yourself 30 seconds once
you've finished up even if you get
distracted too soon even if you haven't
done as much as you wanted even if the
day has become sideswiped take 30
seconds at some point and just sit with
the enjoyment of being a person that did
a hard thing
this is from hardwiring Happiness by
Rick Hansen and I'm really starting to
lean into this despite the fact that I
had him on the show four years ago
um
allowing yourself to feel gratitude and
enjoyment for things well done shortly
after you do them
reinforces the positive pattern
of encouraging you to do it again and
that is not something that should be
taken lightly like it is really really
powerful so
restrict the apps that you use maybe
cold turkey maybe something else that
would be effective make it as
frictionless as possible laptops in the
right place keyboard's all set out
everything's charged everything's ready
to go the drinks there it's chilled it's
blah blah blah you've got all the stuff
um and then feel good once you've done
it
Ahmed Muhammad I was the one that always
wondered how you quote and remember
things from what you have read and stuff
I wish you could share your techniques
this is what I said at the very
beginning dude I was embarrassed of my
recall ability and it's just because I
permanently have a platform to teach
other people or another person about it
and the friends that I spend time with
the guy that I live with we are
permanently having interesting
conversations about topics that I care
about
if you find someone that you can have a
genuinely in-depth conversation with
just lean into that
read a thing teach it to someone read a
thing teach it to someone explain it
reword it
that will
fix it in your mind that will cement it
into your brain pretty effectively
Tucker Dixon if you were to advise
someone to quit either soda or booze
which is the bigger health impact booze
all day like don't even think twice if
that's if if that's a genuine question
uh dude get rid of the booze it's gonna
make a a world of difference to you so
and I mean Xavier supposed to be good
for you maybe
not sponsored
uh Marcus Phillipson uh what is your
best advice for Aspire aspiring
podcasters speech coach acting classes
improve vocabulary
do a hundred episodes do 100 episodes
before you start [__] about with
anything just spend
either between one and two years
doing your show
and get that time and attention in it
would be like saying
um
what
specific formulation of protein powder
do you think I should we eat in my post
Perry training window
how long have you been going to the gym
I haven't yet gone to the gym if you
have if you have accumulated a
significant number of podcast episodes
the next thing that I would suggest that
you do would be review game tape go back
over the things that you're doing uh it
would be make sure that you are fully
prepared so sleep hydration food
uh uh vocal warm-up which you could get
from a speech coach then I did I didn't
use the speech coach for the first
three and a half years maybe like three
yeah three and a half years of the
podcast I didn't have one and miles is
phenomenal the guy that I've worked with
is great however
he was
like the sprinkles on the top of the
icing on the top of the cake he rounded
everything out almost all of the
development and this is for everybody
that's been asking about using a speech
coach or going to improv or doing acting
classes and stuff almost all of the
I would say 95 percent
or maybe even more
of the skill that was accumulated was
done
simply from time and attention of doing
the show
so it is very much it is not the key is
not the acting class or The Improv or
the comedy coaching or the speech
coaching it is doing the thing a lot and
being attentive when you do it paying
attention
uh Chris yabsley any advice on how to
reduce the chances of overcorrecting
during self-improvement I feel that
self-improvement can often lead into
states of feeling inadequate could this
be detrimental when for example pursuing
a new relationship or entering the
dating Market over correcting during
self-improvement
feeling inadequate okay so this would be
maybe an interesting book for you to
read would be uh the gap or the gain by
uh
um
come on
he wrote genius blogging come on
Christopher
nope forgotten his name anyway it's
called The Gap of the game um he's been
on the show twice
but it is late so
my point being
when you are focused on comparing where
you are now with where you want to be
versus where you are now with where you
used to be you are always living in the
Gap as opposed to living in the gain
which would be the opposite uh yes
spending time doing self-improvement
immediately posits an ideal as soon as
you posit an ideal you then begin to
compare yourself to that ideal and the
Gap is pretty painful you notice oh my
God look at all of the things that I
could should would be doing
but look at how far you've come you've
nailed it you're like a million miles
further ahead than where you were and
almost everybody else as well
living in the Gap is not helping you it
is not pushing you forward that much
more fears of insufficiency and a
fundamental
uh
lack of fulfillment from the progress
that you have made isn't pushing you
that much further
so first off let go of that let go of
that belief allow yourself to feel
pleasure and and uh pride in what you
have done and I think it could be
detrimental actually I do think that a
lot of guys you know uh nofap is a
perfect example of this like nofap very
well may benefit a lot of men to get
them away from
poor habits around porn and their own
penis
however
breaking a streak makes them feel so bad
that it might be a net negative for them
I think the over correcting during
self-improvement uh and the states are
feeling inadequate are a phase and I
think that you will grow out of the
phase
um maybe you're in the trenches right
now and it sucks and I've been there I
honestly genuinely have
just
stick to the plan continue to iterate
continue to improve continue to do the
things every single day you will get
better and over time you will look back
and the old version of you even the
version now that asked that question
will be [__] unrecognizable it's
pretty cool
Dave in capital letters what new
information did you learn in the last
year that most change your perspective
on something uh biggest change has been
this hormonal birth control thing like
pretty shocking Dr Sarah Hill your brain
on birth control
one year ago if you'd said to me do you
think that hormonal birth control should
be uh uh restricted re-educated
um or or that women should be encouraged
to maybe cycle naturally I would have
said like [__] no what are you talking
about whereas now I think it might
actually be unethical to not do that uh
which is pretty crazy and anyone that
hasn't considered the dangerous
psychological impact of putting women
young girls on hormones at age 13 or 14
like
you should check out the episode I did
with Dr Sarah Hill it's it's crazy
um Joel Snape what's the number one
thing you look for in a podcast guest
that's a good question
I might be giving a symposium giving a
symposium be part of a symposium at
hbess which is the human
behavioral evolutionary Society
conference in
somewhere on the East Coast so I would
actually be part of a proper academic
conference and I get to do 15 minutes
and it's how to not suck as an academic
guest on a podcast
um
what do I look for what were the points
I put up in there uh good storytelling
um
good communication
uh for I really need the guest to have
some sort of existing media presence not
because I want to capitalize on their
platform but just because I need to be
able to work out whether or not they can
do the thing it's very rare that I bring
somebody on the podcast that I can't see
uh a existing video or episode of I need
to see if they can
communicate their ideas effectively I'll
roll the dice with someone that has an
amazing insight and just go like uh
going to Bogle perfect example the guy's
a digital ghost except for my podcast
like it just doesn't exist on the
Internet it's like Twitter sub stack and
modern wisdom and that's it but I
figured he writes so well he can't even
if he talks 90 worse than the way that
he writes he's still going to be a top
tier AAA guest and sure enough he was
um that's a really good I think it's
storytelling I think it's presentation I
think it is uh genuinely novel insights
um and it's having a good vibe like you
can get a long way with just having a uh
like a good
uh Dynamic a nice a nice Dynamic to you
uh Greg Hill do you engage in a
gratitude practice you'd like to share
so I did formal uh gratitude for a long
time I have filled up 10 Diaries I think
of six months um I did a lot an awful
lot maybe even more
uh
I did I did it for a very very long time
every single morning and most evenings
however I have stopped that now I have
found that I have a limited amount of
time on the morning and the most bang
for my book
um things that I do in my morning
routine
walk
breath work meditation read start the
day previously added into that would
have been
uh journaling gratitude
uh
uh Rehabilitation something like romwad
or a Mobility Program
and then cooking but I'm eating out so
much in Austin that that's pointless
gratitude I would just get this six
minute diary or the five minute success
Journal
um something like that handwritten I
think is good because first thing in the
morning and last thing in the night you
don't want to be on your phone uh and
they're both great the six minute diary
I think you can still get if you use
mw15 on their website in the Europe you
still might be able to get a discount on
that but it's like the both of these
things are 20 bucks or 30 bucks for six
months so just do that
Anand yadav
what would your advice to a 20 year old
struggling through life in relationships
what would what would be your advice to
a 20 year old struggling through life in
relationships
I need more information than that bro
um
it will get better I can tell you that
much as you grow up as you become more
mature your ability to deal with the
vicissitudes of life gets
it's so much better I me and Zach my
housemate were talking about this a lot
the other day which is we think that now
is the golden years looking back I think
that this is going to be the period of
my life where I'm like that was [__]
dope
I was sufficiently young to still have
all of my health and my strength and my
energy uh but I was sufficiently old to
have all of my maturity and if you are
let's say that you are 20 20 year old
dude you I've got so much Headroom for
uh progress and development and I know
that right now might feel like your
entire world is imploding or it this is
your world
but
this is such Boomer advice this I sound
like my mother talking to me here
um yeah over time you're going to look
at the little blips that you have now
especially if you're doing the sorts of
things that the people that listen to
this kind of a podcast do
you're going to look back and laugh at
the things that worried you I always I
always wish that there was a way to take
a photo of the texture of your mind you
know like take a record somehow or have
a time machine where you could um go
back and just experience what it used to
be like
to
feel the texture of your own mind five
years ago or ten years ago and I think
if you were able to do that
you would be amazed at how much more
resilient and peaceful and calm and
balanced you are now and you think oh my
God I can't believe I used to be
bothered about this sort of stuff and in
six months or a year's time this is
exactly how you're going to feel I
promise you this is exactly how you're
going to feel
do the things that you need to do
take time in nature get some sunlight
get up at the same time go to bed at the
same time eat well drink well train have
people around you that you can talk to
about things that you're interested in
continue to iterate continue to develop
follow your curiosity
basic things will continue to carry you
through they will get you through good
times and they will get you through bad
times
and once you're out the other side of
this little period of relationships you
will find another amazing relationship
and
everything will be sweet
look I'm going to leave it there uh that
was longer than I intended but these
were really fun and I think by the time
this goes up we're going to be halfway
to 800 um I don't know
what I should do about
the 100K things once we break a million
it's a crazy thing to say but I really
don't know should I keep doing 100K Q
A's every 100K what if it ends up being
every month is that going to be Overkill
I feel like it might be Overkill
um but
thank you anyway uh brilliant like such
such good
uh questions today I really really
genuinely do appreciate all of you I
love the comments I love the comments
section I love the fact that you correct
other people that steaming that are
obviously being too unreasonable uh you
guys are all great
love you
see you at 800k
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]